je vécus avec moque de douleur ces
moments difficiles que vit marque public
mon pays je vais profiter
là où je suis de lancer un appel au
calme à la sérénité leur population
haïtienne demandé au président de la
république au premier ministre au
gouvernement de parler de discuter avec
l'opposition demandé à l'opposition
justement de discuter avec le pouvoir en
place
2 je voudrais en profiter pour lancer un
appel au calme à la sérénité parce que
ces images on envoie au monde entier ne
peuvent en aucun cas aider à la
construction de la république pour les
populations à l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des populations qui
souffrent le moment est venu où il
faudra entendre une fausse nous devons
nous entendre il faut une entente
nationale il faut de la concertation
le tout à l'occasion avec arrivée mais
personne ne peut le faire tout seul
c'est ensemble qu'on peut le faire la
diaspora à tout le peuple haïtien se
trouvent partout dans le monde
je demande du temps la sérénité ensemble
nous pouvons reconstruire haïti
la paix c'est le premier débat public la
stabilité
engageons nous pour qu'elle revienne
dano bruce de nos foyers sur l'ensemble
du territoire
alors ces événements ont débuté à la
date du 18 novembre
c'est une date importante dans
l'histoire d'haïti et pour vous on
n'aurait pas dû commencer sous
manifestations à saint-denis et p6 nous
fait dire que risquent ils
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la fosse d'haïti
c'est son histoire sa culture sa
jeunesse
on aurait pu on aurait pu engager les
manifestations avant ou après et
préserver le 10 novembre qui emprisonne
date extraordinaire dans l'histoire
universelle parce que au fait les
esclaves au mit ont mis un terme à l'
esclavage en défiant la première armée
du monde qui de l'armée napoléonienne et
sauve en 1803 et ça fait partie de
l'histoire universelle donc comme ceux
ci n'a pas été fait donc je pense que
dans les années à venir
de même chaque citoyen haïtien chanson
haïtienne chaque groupe ou bien va
devoir comprendre un jeu qu'il ya la
confirmation de cette date historique
qui témoigne de l'importance du peuple
haïtien dans la lutte que nos ancêtres
ont mené à bien pour donner un exemple
de liberté qui constitue aujourd'hui la
toile de fond de toute démocratie de du
système démocratique